so here we are together
but we're in a technological trance
here we are together but we're divided
by tribalism
here we are together but we're
distracted by mass myths
we've been separated by walls windows
computer screens borders
but we're united in our hearts
or we've argued and quarreled in the
past
but now we know we've got a common bond
humanity
so why are we all here
maybe we're all looking for a key
a key to unlock this political economic
social cultural
paralysis
maybe the answer is in a little word
empathy
empathy is not just walking in someone's
shoes or feeling someone's pain
empathy is the secret ingredient
for finding a human connection
so i want you to open up your hearts and
open up your minds because in times of
confusion we must not lose our capacity
to dare to be kind to each other
some years ago
i had the great privilege to be invited
to the white house to do this
now this has got nothing to do with
politics
this is a cultural moment in american
history this is michelle obama's first
portrait as first lady
thank you
so um on this day i was nervous
and when i'm nervous i get socially
clumsy know what i mean
so i picked up my camera
focused on her eyelash
and in my clumsiness i shouted out right
my love i want your soul give it to me
silence in the room
i'm sure the hairdresser almost dropped
the hairspray in shock
and as i took this picture this
devastating look came over her face the
eyebrow raises as if to say how dare you
but i quite like it at the same time
so then i realized what i just said and
i said my goodness me i'm an englishman
and in england we invented being polite
i think canadians and americans do it
better now but we invented it and here i
am in the white house calling you my
love and demanding your soul please
forgive my atrocities
she stands up
gives me a hug
and whispers in my ear platinum when all
is said and done
i'm just michelle
this is [ __ ] riot
you probably know them as the hardcore
feminist punk rock group who spoke truth
to power against putin's excessive
nationalism
and consequently they were sent
to a siberian prison for two years
but what happens if we remove those
colorful aggressive masks
you see something different
this is nadia and marsha
photographed after they were released
from prison
look at their faces you can see the
vulnerability on their faces you can see
that they've paid a heavy price for
their support of lgbtq rights and
women's rights in russia
now
during their trial in the courtroom
before jail
they were kept in a big cage as if
they're wild animals
nadia
the woman with dark hair
the co-founder of [ __ ] riot
she was constantly scribbling
handwritten notes on a scrappy piece of
paper
eventually the judge said to her i want
you to stand up and make your closing
statement before i sentence you i'm sure
nadia must have known she's about to go
to jail
nevertheless
she stood up
nervously clutching her piece of paper
took a deep breath
and read out from her notes and what she
said to the judge and to the world i
believe will go down as one of our
generation's greatest speeches
she said
i wouldn't give people labels
there are no winners or losers here
injured parties or accused we just need
to make contact
to establish a dialogue and a joint
search for truth to seek wisdom together
to be philosophers together rather than
stigmatizing and labeling people that is
one of the worst things people could do
i believe nadia thinks one of the worst
things we could do
is to judge each other
maybe we need to be less judgmental
and more curious
when you look at one of my pictures
you might find yourself making judgments
about that person
so what happens if i strip away your
capacity to make those judgments i take
away 95 of the picture and i leave you
with just five percent that you can't
recognize
but maybe it's the most important part
the window to someone's character
the eye
whose eye is this
always watching us
is it someone you love is it someone you
hate
it belongs
to this man
this
man
at this moment
i would like to pay tribute
to all the courageous
brave
resilient heroes who fight against
oppression
who fight for human rights
dignity
freedom and justice around the world
let's give them a round of applause
[Music]
so i was driven through the streets of
moscow past the gates of the kremlin and
we continued out of the streets of
moscow into a dark bleak gothic forest
we arrived at one of the most sinister
buildings i've ever seen in my life his
private residence his private dasher
and it was surrounded by a two-story
high security wall with snipers all the
way along the top
as i
get out of the limo i'm escorted into
the building at gunpoint
i'm led into a room
i waited and he comes in with a giant
entourage and i said mr president
before i capture this moment of history
on film i've got a question i'd like to
ask you
i said i was brought up by my mum and
dad
listening to the music of the beatles
i want to know if you ever listened to
the beatles
his two translators whisper in his ear
there's some confusing looks amongst the
entourage
and then his mood drops
and in russian he orders the two
translators and all his political
advisers out of the room immediately
the bodyguards stay
and then putin turns to me
and in perfect english he says
i love the beatles
i said i didn't know you spoke english
he said i speak perfect english i said
in that case who's your favorite beatle
he said paul i said what's your favorite
song is it back in the ussr
yeah he didn't like that very much
and then he said no
my favorite song is yesterday
think about it
and i thought about it
and i realized i'm being sent a
subliminal message about the old days of
power and authority of the soviet union
through a paul mccartney song
now
that human connection i had with him
allowed me in and i ended up about an
inch and a half away from his nose as i
took this picture i could feel his cold
breath on my hand as i focus the lens
and that's how i got the truth
the truth is that this is the cold face
of power and authority in russia
and then
he performs power for me in his chair
now the lgbtq community and the human
rights community in russia many of their
members have adopted my pictures of
putin
and they use them as a banner to show
everything that they believe is wrong
with power in their country
i've been told recently
that anyone in russia who is caught
circulating my pictures online in
connection with human rights violations
will be arrested and they will go to
jail immediately
whose eye is this
someone you love someone you hate
it belongs to a man
who was prepared to go to jail for his
beliefs
the late great
muhammad ali
i said to him muhammad
you are the greatest
teach me to be great how can my
generation be as great as your
generation had to be during the civil
rights era
he couldn't speak very well because of
parkinson's
so i had to get close and he whispered
i have a confession to make
what is it i said he said i wasn't as
great as i said i was
holy [ __ ] i said
that's the biggest confession i ever
heard in my life the whole world knows
you as ali the greatest
and then he said
i think you misunderstand me
i'll tell you what was great he said
it wasn't me
it was the people saw themselves in my
struggle
in my story
and then he turned it to me and now i've
got the great honor
to turn it to you
and he said
if you can get people to see themselves
in the story that you put forward then
you have a chance of achieving greatness
but that greatness is never you
personally
that's something much bigger
called bridge building
a light bulb went off in my brain so i
took this picture
my last ever portrait of muhammad ali
not as a prize fighter or a champion but
as a compassionate bridge builder
thinking of the underdog
whose eye is this
someone you love someone you hate
a different type of underdog
belongs to this man
so i said to him donald
let's be human with each other just for
a few minutes
we've all followed your career i said no
one can doubt it's an extraordinary
career path you've had
but there's always something about you
there's always an air of tension and
controversy about things you say and do
in public and i'm sure that's
intentional on your part but it feels to
me as if you're in the middle of an
emotional storm
personally i couldn't live with that
anxiety all the time i want to know how
you weather the storm
he calmly looks at me and he says
i am the storm
the eyes are always watching us
but how do we use
our eyes
do we look
or do we see
when you look at this picture you might
find your self thinking about the
politics of war
but when you see the person in this
picture
you get to know jessica
jessica holds a flag they draped over
her husband's coffin who had recently
been killed fighting in iraq for america
i took this picture in her home
now she has his wedding ring around her
neck on a chain
when you're killed in combat the us
military sends your clothes and personal
belongings back to the family in a big
box
jessica had recently received the box
but had not yet had the courage to open
it
there it lay closed at the base of her
bed in her bedroom
i said to her jessica maybe you should
wear one of his army t-shirts as a
tribute to him in the picture she said i
would
but all his t-shirts are in the box
maybe now she said
it's time for me to face that emotion
so we both walked into her bedroom
we both knelt at the base of her bed
and we undid a latch each of the box and
lifted the lid
and she burst into tears
and i felt
ashamed of myself
for the first time in my life i had put
a photograph above the well-being of a
person
as i apologize she said you don't
understand why i'm crying
i'm trying she said
because i just realized they washed his
clothes and i wanted to smell him again
did you feel that
did you feel
that
if you felt that
then something beautiful just happened
we all came into this room
defined by our differences
men women old young black white dare i
say members of the left
dare i say members of the right
different genders
different religious groups cultures
but we all felt that
together what we felt is compassion
compassion for someone you've never even
met that's the power of human connection
and that's why we will not go down as
the generation of connectivity that
disconnected itself no
i think we're going to rise up
i think we're going to rekindle the
spirit of optimism
it seems to me they underestimated the
resilience of
humanity whose eye is this
someone you love
someone you hate
it belongs
to a man who was robbed of the power of
human connection
professor stephen hawking
now he was very ill when i took this
picture
in fact his whole body had essentially
shut down there was only one muscle he
could still work and that was underneath
his eye
his team of scientists placed a sensor
at the base of his glasses you can see
it here
and that sensor picks up movement of
that muscle and with that muscle he
moves a cursor over each letter of the
alphabet on his laptop screen
he chooses a letter builds a word
constructs a paragraph and that's how he
communicated those epic statements about
space time and humanity to us
at the end of the session i said to him
professor
what an honor it is for me to photograph
you and i've seen how hard it is for you
to even communicate but i'm gonna ask
for a big favor
i said i want one word of wisdom from
you one word from you
it's going to be worth a million words
from anyone else
we all waited
his nurse was a little concerned
i had heard that that muscle was failing
and most of the things he typed around
this time didn't mean anything
suddenly we heard
beep
beep
beep beep
he was typing
we all leaned in
to the laptop screen to see where the
cursor's going to go
and he went all the way to the letter w
then he starts the next letter
all the way to the letter o
and then the final letter
all the way back
to the letter
w
someone on the team said w-o-w what does
that stand for that's nonsense it's a
mistake
and i said hold on a minute
that's not a mistake
he just typed the word wow
he just gave me a word my kids would use
about the beauty and majesty of life and
isn't it amazing how the man who faces
so much adversity still looks at the
world through the eyes of wonder
his nurse said
he's exhausted
let's give his eyes a rest let's take
off his sensor take off his glasses and
replace them with his dark sunglasses
and then i saw it
a vision of a badass rock star of hope
and i took this picture this is my
fitting tribute to a legend of our time
a man who believed that connection
equals compassion
so i'm not gonna leave you with an
answer
i'm gonna leave you
with a question
are we to be bystanders like moths
dancing around somebody else's flame
or are we to be upstanders and we light
darkness ourselves with our own torch of
compassion because when there is light
we see each other
not as strangers
not as opponents
but as creative partners
and then together
we rebuild this troubled world
together we reconnect
together we earn the respect of history
and transform this chaos
into a beautiful cosmos
thank you for listening to me
[Applause]
bye